[MUSIC]
DAVID WANG: Hi, my name's Dave.
I'm a product manager
here at Google,
and I'm really excited
to be here today.
So today, Jeff Archer
and I are going
to show you how transactions
work on the Google Assistant.
So we were super excited
to launch Actions on Google
last December, opening
the door for developers
like you to create great
experiences for the Google
Assistant.
However, there were
a couple of gaps.
So first, actions on Google
only worked on the Google Home.
So as we announced this
week, that's changed.
Actions on Google is
now available on phones,
and now any developer can build
great multimodal experiences
for the Google Assistant.
Second, Actions on Google
didn't support transactions,
and that's what we're
here to discuss today.
Let's see one in action.
Order delivery from Panera.
AUDIO PLAYBACK:
Hi, this is Panera.
For delivery, I'll
just need the address.
Which one can I get from Google?
What can I get you started with?
DAVID WANG: I need
something with bacon in it.
AUDIO PLAYBACK: Got it.
How about one of
these cold drinks?
DAVID WANG: Power smoothie.
AUDIO PLAYBACK: Great, are
you ready to check out?
DAVID WANG: Yes.
AUDIO PLAYBACK: Here's
your order summary.
Your total is $17.74.
Ready to place the order?
DAVID WANG: Yes.
AUDIO PLAYBACK:
Thanks, you're all set.
By the way, I can sign you up
today for a MyPanera account.
Are you interested?
DAVID WANG: I
heard they give you
free pastries with every
account creation, so yes.
One more tap to
create my account.
AUDIO PLAYBACK: Congrats.
You're now our newest member.
See you next time.
DAVID WANG: And look, I
already have a notification
from Panera.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
And they're super quick,
so my delivery is going
to arrive in just 20 minutes.
I tap into that, and look,
here's my full receipt
with some follow-up
actions on the bottom.
Pretty cool, right?
So let's review
what just happened.
I was a customer who never
interacted with Panera before.
I was able to share my
payment and my address
with a single tap.
I created a new Panera
account with just two taps.
Panera updated me on the status
of my order via notification.
And finally, I was
able to pull up
all of the details of the order,
including follow-up actions,
from my assistant order history.
So let's back up.
The way that users
interact with technology
is fundamentally changing.
This has been the
theme for the past year
with Google Assistant.
So we're in the middle
of a shift from web
to app to assistants.
So from clicks to
swipes to voice.
And good assistants,
human assistants,
are useful for a number reasons.
They know who you are.
They know your
payment information.
They know your friends
and your contacts.
They know your
preferences, like if you
like skim milk in your
coffee, or if you like
the aisle seat on the airline.
They're always with you.
They're accessible 24 hours
a day, from your home,
in your car, in
your living room,
when you're out and about,
and they're easy to use.
You just talk to them, and
they do all the hard work.
But assistants
can't do everything.
They can't make you pizzas.
They can't drive
you to the airport.
A real assistant has more
than just information.
They help you get things
done in the real world,
and the Google Assistant
needs an ecosystem of partners
to help us do that.
Good ecosystems need three
things to be successful.
So over the long
term, users are only
going to use the Google
Assistant if it's powerful,
if it's actually the easiest
way to get things done.
It can't just be a novelty.
And over the long
term, developers
are only going to invest in
building apps for the Google
Assistant if there's a
return on that investment.
You have to be able
to monetize it.
So to create this
virtuous cycle,
Assistant really
needs to provide value
to both users and developers.
One way we're addressing
this is with distribution.
We're bringing Assistant
and Actions on Google
to lots of users and services,
starting with Google Home back
in December.
Now it's available on Android
and iOS, and in the future
we're going to support
Android TV Allo, wear, auto,
and even non-Google devices via
the Assistant SDK, assistants
built into a drink-mixing
machine right outside.
So we're going to have
the audience, hundreds
of millions of users.
How do transactions fit in?
So first, what are transactions
in the Google Assistant
context?
They could be purchases,
like food delivery or concert
tickets, or they could be
reservations and appointments,
so for example, a haircut,
a restaurant, or yoga class.
And why do transactions
matter to our ecosystem?
One, it's good for users.
It bridges the gap between
information and action,
between the assistant knowing
things and the assistant
doing things that helps
users in the real world
and makes our lives easier.
It's also good for developers.
You can find new users, you
can re-engage existing users,
and more importantly, you
can monetize your actions
on Google app.
So if transactions are good for
everybody, what's the problem?
Simple.
Buying stuff can be
really hard, right?
There's a lot of friction.
There's a lot of places
for people to drop off,
and two of the
biggest pain points
are with payments and identity.
So let's say you're
in real life.
You go to the store, take
an item off the shelf,
you go to the cashier
and you pay for it.
So it's pretty simple.
It's just not very convenient.
What if what you
wanted was sold out,
or how did you know what was
on sale before you got there?
What if what you want is
cheaper somewhere else?
With apps, you have
to download the app,
you enter your
payment information
and your personal details like
your address and your phone,
and then finally, you build
your cart and you pay.
OK, it's not too bad,
but this gets really old
if you have to do this for
every single app, and worse,
every time you
switch a device, you
have to download the
app again, and then you
have to sign in again.
On top of that, a lot of
assistant transactions
today require all
that, and you also
have to create an
account with the app,
and then link that
account to the assistant,
and then finally you can pay.
It's just not really that easy.
So Google already has
users' payment and identity
information, and, like
a human assistant,
Google Assistant can
facilitate transactions
on the user's behalf by passing
that information to you.
So less friction means more
purchases, happier users
and happier developers.
So let's recap.
Transactions on
Actions on Google
has three major
platform features.
We already talked about
the first two, which
are payments and identity.
The third is
re-engagement, which
we'll discuss in a little bit.
These features are
implemented independently.
You don't need to implement
Google-facilitated payments
to get streamlined
identity and vice versa,
but good flows really do
incorporate all three.
Let's go into a bit more
detail, starting with payments.
Did you know up to
a third of users
are going to abandon a
checkout flow if they
have to enter a credit card?
So here's the thing--
anyone who's ever
purchased an Android app
or rented a movie
from Google Play
already has a card
on file with Google.
Users have already
saved hundreds
of millions of debit and credit
cards to their Google accounts,
and Google can securely pass
that payment information to you
during an Assistant transaction.
Here's how it works.
First, you tell Google you
need to charge a certain amount
to a certain user.
Google then encrypts the raw
credit card information with
your payment possessor's key--
and this is specific to you--
and then it generates an
encrypted payment credential.
Google then passes
you that credential,
and then you charge it like
you would any normal debit
or credit card.
That's it.
Google-facilitated
payments are convenient.
For users, it's a
single tap to pay.
It's free.
Google doesn't charge
a fee for this.
You just pay the
standard processing fees
to your payment processor,
and it's lightweight.
Just indicate at runtime that
you need a payment credential,
and we'll figure it out.
You charge it like you
would a normal credit card.
These are the payment
processors we support today,
and we have more coming online
in the next several months.
And of course, using
Google-facilitated payments
is completely optional.
If your customers already have
a payment method with you--
for example, a loyalty
card or points--
you can use that, too.
So that said, let's talk about
the second platform feature--
seamless identity.
So half of all users are going
to abandon a flow if they have
to create a new account,
and up to 90% of users
will leave, abandon
the flow altogether,
if they forget their password
or login information.
So imagine you're interacting
with the user on the Assistant,
and you'd like the user to
either sign in or create
a new account.
There's a really good chance
you're going to lose that user.
Over half of users are going
to drop out at this point,
and this gets even worse if
the user has to switch devices.
So for example, a
Google Home user
has to enter their user name
and password on a phone,
but since every Google
Assistant user has an identity
to find with Google, Google can
share that identity with you
to create or link an
account on your system.
These identity assertion
flows make linking seamless.
Just two taps, and you're done.
And this could even work in
eyes-free hands-free scenarios,
so users can link
to existing accounts
or create new accounts with
you without ever picking up
their phone.
Here's how it works.
When the user taps their account
chip in this [INAUDIBLE],
Google sends you
an identity token.
That token contains information
such as the user's name
and email address.
You use the contents
of that token
to look up the user
in your system.
If they don't have an
account with you yet,
you can create one using
the user's Google identity.
This works similarly
to Google sign in.
If they do already have
an account with you,
you can optionally ask the user
to accept additional OAuth 2
scripts to complete the
account-making process.
These assertion flows are
easy to implement on top
of existing OAuth 2 flows.
So we've already got
some really good feedback
from our early access
partners about this.
With relatively
incremental investment,
you can minimize that huge
drop-off on account linking
and account creation.
Let's move on to the
third platform feature--
re-engagement.
Transactions don't stop
when the user pays.
Users may have questions
about the order.
So for example, where is it?
What's the status of my return?
Can I add something to
the order before it ships?
Or maybe they want to
take action against it.
They want to move
the appointment,
or maybe upgrade their
seat to first class,
or refill a prescription.
Google Assistant maintains
all that transaction history
in a single place,
makes it really
easy for users to find an
order and re-engage with it.
Users can easily initiate
these follow-up actions
that you define for your orders,
both from the transaction
history or simply by
asking the assistant.
You can also reach back
out to your customers
by providing order
updates, because users
care when their
Uber is arriving,
or if the salon needs
to cancel the haircut.
Users can stay up to date
about their orders with you
without having to
download your app
or search through their email.
So that wraps up our overview
of the main platform features.
Now Jeff is going to walk
us through how to integrate
transactions into your app.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF CAESAR: Well, we're
super excited to be opening up
the developer
preview for Assistant
transactions this week.
The transactions API
is part of the Actions
on Google framework,
so before we
get into this new
API, let's first start
with a brief review
of how you use Actions
to build Assistant apps.
For more detailed instructions
on getting started with
Assistant apps, go to
developers.google.com/actions,
and you can also check out
yesterday's IO talk on building
apps for the Google Assistant,
which is now available
on YouTube.
So an assistant app is simply
a set of web hook endpoints
that receive a request
from the assistant
for each turn of a
conversation with the user.
So when a user
talks to your app,
the Google Assistant
transcribes the user's input
and sends it to
your app as text.
So you can use whatever
web server and language
you like for your
web hook, though we
like to use Node.js
for its simplicity,
and we also provide a client
library to make it easier
to work with the request
and response formats.
You can get the client
library within an NPM
install actions on Google.
So you work with the raw
text input in your web hook,
or you can use a natural
language understanding
tools such as api.ai, which will
convert this text into a higher
level parametrized user intent.
So we'll use apa.ai and
Node.js for all the examples
in our talk today.
So in the example
here, a user would
like to order a classic burger.
Api.ai matches this to an add
item intent in a classic burger
entity that you would
have already defined
in the api.ai tool, and then
sends us along to your web hook
as part of the JSON payload.
So you can respond to the
user in a number of ways,
including a simple
response, which
takes the form of either a
chat bubble or text to speech,
or you can also send
rich responses, which,
in addition to the
simple response,
can include other
components such as cards
and lists or suggestion chips.
So in this example, we're using
the Node.js client library
to build a card as the response.
The card contains an image, some
suggestion chips for the user,
and other information.
We typically respond
with app.ask,
which will open the
mic to accept the user
input for the next turn
of the conversation.
So that's simple
in rich responses.
The third type of response
is to call a helper.
So when you respond to
an assistant request
by invoking a helper,
this tells the assistant
to momentarily take
over the conversation
to obtain some specific
information for your app.
This is done in a
standardized way
but still using the
voice of your app.
So for example,
a helper could be
used to get a confirmation
from the user,
meaning a yes or no
response to a question,
and then return
this to your app.
So you can think of this
from your app's perspective
as a two-step process.
So you tell the assistant
what information
you need from the user, and
then that information is then
passed back to you
on the next request.
So it's these
helpers that we use
to handle the transactional
part of your conversation
with the user.
So let's take a typical
e-commerce scenario
where you have one or more
dialogue turns with the user
to construct their
basket of goods.
So you might have a
simple single-item basket
that you might be able to
satisfy with a single dialogue
turn, or maybe you have
something more complicated,
like our food ordering
example, where
you can have lots of items
and add-ons and adjustments.
So you use a combination of
the simple and rich responses,
such as the carousel
that we see here,
to build this basket
of goods with the user.
Once this basket's
established, then you
use the transaction
helpers to take
the user through the checkout.
So therefore, transaction
helper's available.
The first is ask for
delivery address.
So this gets a delivery
address from the user,
allowing them to select from
their stored address book,
and then sent back to you.
The second is the-- is
to propose or present
the order to the user.
So here, you indicate
to the user what
it is that they're buying, and
you receive their acceptance
back on the next turn, often
with their payment credentials.
Next is the confirmation
of the order step.
So upon receiving the user's
acceptance of the order
from your app, you then
confirm back to the user
that you received it
and it's a good order.
As part of this
turn, you'll also
show a summary of the
order to the user.
And finally, Google
account-linking.
So as Dave mentioned,
this allows the user
to sign in or create an
account with your service using
your OAuth 2 server, or,
if you support the OAuth 2
assertion flows, users can
sign in or create accounts
using just a couple of taps.
So this might be the typical
e-commerce flow, where
the user first builds
their basket of goods,
picks the delivery
address, and then they
go through the checkout
flow and can optionally
create an account.
But it could also be
the case, for example,
that you need an address
first, for example,
to determine inventory
availability, or pricing,
or service area.
So you can certainly
sequence the steps as needed
for your use case, or you
could skip steps entirely.
So for example,
you might not have
an OAuth 2 endpoint, or you--
you're fine with the
guest checkout flow,
so you don't need to
ask the user to sign in.
And even with your
best-laid plans,
users manage to keep things
interesting when you're
building conversation apps.
So for example, the
user could decide
to add something to
their basket when
they're at the checkout step,
or maybe change their address.
So in this case, you might
need to modify or recalculate
the order, and then
present it to the user
again for their acceptance.
So the transaction
helpers can help
handle these different
responses from the user
and send them back to your
app as text or intents.
The only two required
steps in the flow
are to propose the
order so the user
can see exactly what it is
that they're purchasing,
then, again, the
assistant will collect
the user's authorization
for that order,
and then to confirm
the order with user
after it's been placed.
You should also send
updates about the order
as it's fulfilled.
And we'll talk more about
that in a few minutes.
So the basic data structure for
every transaction is an order.
Each order has a cart where you
specify line items, sub line
items, and notes.
And so for example,
in our burger example,
a hamburger might
be a line item,
and a bacon add-on
would be a sub line,
and you might have
medium rare in the notes.
So item versus sub item
really only affects
the presentation of the
receipt that the user sees.
So it's really your
choice as to how
you structure the cart in a
way that the user can clearly
understand what it is
that they're purchasing.
And then on the
order itself, you'll
set fees and other adjustments,
total price, delivery address,
and overall image for the order.
So once you propose the order,
once you present the order
to the user and the
user authorizes it,
the assistant then sends
the order back to your app
with some additional
data added to it.
So this includes
an initial status,
so this will typically be the
value created that we set.
You'll also receive the
payment method for this order
if you're using a
Google-facilitated payment.
We'll set a creation time
on the order, as well as
a Google-generated order ID.
So those are the common
flows and data structure
that we use for transactions.
So now that we have
that, let's take a look
at how this works in the code.
So we first define the function.
I'm going to define the function
here that creates a cart
and stores it in the
app data session state.
So to create our cart, we call
app.buildCart, [? inset ?]
some merchant metadata--
again, that's just
going to appear in the receipt.
Next we define the
structure of the cart
through line items
and sub lines.
So for this example, I've
hard coded items for the cart,
but of course, in a real app,
you would determine these--
the set of items over of your
dialogue turns with the user.
So here we're adding
our burger with bacon,
and also specifying
unique IDs, which
are required for each
item in the order,
as well as the
price and quantity
and other standard information.
So now, if you require
a delivery address,
you call the ask for
delivery address helper.
You should-- when
you call this, you
should also provide some
additional context for the user
so they understand why they're
giving their address to you.
The user's response comes
back as the delivery address
complete intent in the
subsequent request, which
I've mapped to a function of
the same name in this example.
Here, we check that the
delivery address was sent back
by the user, and if so,
we store it in app.data.
Then we'll ask the user if
they're ready to check out,
and then we'll check out on the
next turn of the conversation.
So if the user chose not
to provide an address
in this example, as we
see in the else condition,
well, we can prompt them
again, possibly giving them
an alternative, or maybe
just an escape hatch,
or ending the conversation.
Great, so the user's
given us an address,
and they're ready
to check out, so
let's define a method
to create our order.
So first, we call
app.buildOrder,
we set the cart that we created
and stored in our session
previously, and then we set
the image for the order,
we add tax and other
items for the order,
and finally, the total price.
So now we have our
cart and our order,
and we're going to propose
the order to the user,
present it to the user.
So first we define our payment
configuration parameters.
So in this case, I want Google
to provide a payment instrument
for the user.
This is using
Google-facilitated payments.
So as Dave talked
about earlier, this
allows the user to select
their card on file with Google.
So if I set this input to
the proposed order method,
the user will get a list
of their credit cards
that match the set of filter
criteria that I set up.
So here I'm
specifying that I only
support Visa and
MasterCard, and I'm also
setting the
tokenization parameters
specific to my
payment processor.
In this case, I'm using Stripe.
Next, I call apps for
transaction decision
with this order and
payment configuration.
The order is then
presented to the user,
as you see on the
left, and the assistant
handles all the details of
collecting the user's response,
getting the user's
authorization for the purchase,
and then passes all of the
agreed-upon order and payment
information back to me.
And if-- again,
if you don't want
to use facilitated
payments with this,
you're also free to use your
own app-provided payments
instrument.
So in this example,
I'm simply describing
the form of payment being used
so that the user can actually
see this in the receipt.
And so for example, we
could set the last four
digits of the payment
instrument or loyalty program,
and then this will be displayed
for the user during checkout.
And of course, this
typically requires
that you have the user
signed in and they
have a card on file
with you already
so you know what to charge.
So the benefit of this
is that you still get
to use the same checkout flow
dialogues, user authorization,
and other benefits, but
have the flexibility
of using your own payment
instruments if you choose.
And finally, you can drop a
payment config altogether.
So you can have an
order that doesn't
require any payment at all.
So if you have a reservation
that has no cost,
you can use that, but
still get all the benefits
of the checkout flow.
OK, so the order is
presented by the assistant.
It looks good to the user, and
they authorize the transaction.
Their response is
sent back to your app
as part of the transaction
decision complete intent.
So here you get the
user's decision,
and if the user's accepted, then
you likely call your back end
to create or persist
the order, and likely
call your payment processor
to authorize the card
or charge the card.
Finally, you need to send a
response back to the user,
again, confirming that the
order's been successfully
received by your app, and you
give them the current state
of that order.
So first, you obtain
the Google order
ID so we know which
order you're confirming,
then you create
the rich response.
This time you create
an order update
object, which indicates
initial states, you specify
a final order ID, if it's
changed, and set some text
to include in the response.
This results in the final
receipt confirmation
presented to the user
as you see on the left,
and then the conversation
continues from there.
On this last line with
the else condition,
we have an example of handling
alternate user decisions.
So here the user's chosen
to change their address
during checkout, so
instead of course
being able to charge that card,
we'll send this response back
to you, and you'll have the
option of creating a new order
and presenting it
to the user again.
So this covers the
order creation APIs.
Now I'll hand off to Archita to
talk about follow-up actions.
[APPLAUSE]
ARCHITA VADALI: Now let us talk
about how a system facilitates
the follow-up interactions
between the app
developers and the users
after the conversation ends.
After the order is
placed, you should
send order updates for
all meaningful changes
to the order.
For example, a ride sharing
app might send updates
when the car has arrived.
A food delivery app
might send updates
when the food is delivered.
A restaurant reservation
app might send updates
if the reservation is canceled.
Important updates will trigger
a notification to the user.
All order updates are also
visible in the order history.
You can also attach follow-up
actions to each order update.
In a food delivery
scenario, while the food
is being prepared,
you could have
follow-up actions
like track order,
call restaurant, or cancel.
After the food has
been delivered,
the follow-up actions could be
rate restaurant and re-order.
There are four types
of follow-up actions.
Email and phone are
straightforward.
You might use these for
customer service contacts.
URLs can be deep links
to websites or apps.
For example, you
might want to link
to a live tracker for the
delivery or image of a QR code
for concert tickets.
Intents launch the user
back into a conversation
with your assistant app.
You specify the
intent that should
be triggered, and pre-fill
any arguments, for example,
the order ID.
Your assistant app might let the
users check your return policy,
re-schedule an appointment,
or quickly re-order.
Order updates are
simply POST requests
to an Actions on
Google endpoint.
The following code snippet shows
how to build an order update.
First, populate
the updated state,
along with required
supporting information.
In this example, the
order is in transit.
Next, set the content of
the system notification,
like "your food shop
order is on its way".
Last, add any follow-up
actions to the order update.
These are displayed,
along with the receipt,
in the order of history.
In this example, we have added
a follow-up action of type URLS
to contact the customer service.
Finally, let's
talk about account
linking and account creation.
First, register your OAuth
2 configuration in Actions
on Google Console.
At runtime, check whether
the user has already
linked accounts.
You can do so by verifying
if an OAuth 2 access
token is included in
assistance request to your app.
To start the account
linking flow,
simply call askforSignIn
helper method.
What happens next depends on
the configuration you define
and whether the user already
has an account in your system.
If you support OAuth
assertion flows,
we will send you
a JSON web token.
You can use the contents of
this token to look up the user
it in your system.
If they don't already have an
account, create a new account,
and return the OAuth
2 refresh token.
If they already
have an account, you
may optionally ask the user
to accept additional OAuth 2
scopes to complete the
account-linking flow.
If you don't support
JWT assertion flow,
we will trigger a standard
OAuth 2 account-linking flow
in a web browser.
After the user signs them,
return an OAuth 2 refresh
token.
Now, back to Dave.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID WANG: So we have a great
set of early access partners
already developing transactional
apps for the Google Assistant.
Soon, you'll be able to
send flowers, or buy dinner,
or order concert tickets.
These are just some
initial examples
of how the Actions
on Google ecosystem
is extending the Google
Assistant to help users
in the real world, and to bridge
the gap between it knowing
things and doing things.
Transactions is currently
in developer preview.
You can start adding
transactions into your Actions
on Google apps today.
Please visit the link
here for more details
about our EPIs, documentation,
and helpful libraries.
Actions on Google is also
running a developer challenge,
with prizes including
a trip to I/O 2018.
The consumer experience is
going to launch on phone soon,
and then expand to other
surfaces such as Home, wear,
and more.
We're really excited to see
what you're going to build.
[MUSIC]